euch
man kann ich noch learn to play to this
one
mano khalil und möchte folgen ukulele
spielen holte jetzt auch eben stellen
egal
liebe freunde ich habe mir gedacht ich
mache ein video wo ich böse kommentare
geht mich ungemein komische kommentare
ja freunde ich denke man sieht was ich
als die wird irgendwann sterben
ich glaube man hat so aus dem haus
gehört ich habe mir gedacht ich mache
mal ein video wo ich so ein paar crazy
kommentare die ich in den kommentaren
unter meinen videos gefunden habe dir
wieder böse sind oder etwas anderes
einfach mal vorlesen dazu ein bisschen
stellung nehme und wir fangen an mit dem
ersten kommentare haha ich würde dir so
gerne einen staubsauger in deinen fetish
arschloch stopfen und dabei so hoffen
dass du dabei verrecken würdest du
missgeburt danke ich habe euch jetzt im
nächsten bild was immer eingeblendet
seht mal die fehler unterstrichen diese
person gemacht hat diese gut haha ich
würde dir so gerne einen staubsauger in
den fetten arsch loch stopfen und dabei
so hoffen dass du dabei verrecken
würdest du missgeburt ich liebe das wir
mit mir umgeht das ist richtig schön
under katze und hässlich ich hasse
solche wolkenkratzer auf dem kopf
genervt dass meine ja mal abgesehen
davon dass es eigentlich nicht mal eine
richtige anlage ist sondern nicht an den
seiten immer noch haare habe okay
eigentlich ist es schon ein anderer kann
aber ich finde jetzt nicht mal so krass
also wenn man sich das mal anschaut das
ist jetzt einfach nur dass die hypo oben
länger sind als an den seiten
ich finde ich schlimm ich war damals
auch so total gegen undercut und so was
alles aber ich habe jetzt ja auch keinen
kompletten anerkannt also ich hatte nur
diese leute die an den haaren wirklich
phase eine glatze haben und oben
komplett lange haare und die dann so
komplett drüber und aber ich finde jetzt
eigentlich dass ich kein wolkenkratzer
auf dem kopf oder bin ich eigentlich der
einzige der in conny den deutschen
die pi sieht die pi die pin-nummer davon
aus dass er meint dann weiß ich
allerdings auch nicht ob ich das jetzt
als kompliment ziehen soll
oder als ich meine es gibt viele die
sagen hier das spiel spiele aber du
lebst es nicht in einer datei sondern du
schneidest das ist genauso wie popeye
das ist alles geklaut aber es gibt auch
wiederum leute die sagen hey gespielt
spiele du schnell ist das zusammen das
ist zwar so wie pipi das auch macht dass
er spiele spielt und die zusammen
schneidet allerdings ist das auch cool
und nicht geklaut deswegen weiß ich
nicht wie ich den kommentar
interpretieren soll ich interpretiere
jetzt einfach mal so wie wenn einer zu
einem fußballer sagt hey gespielt sowie
der deutschen messe denn es ist ja auch
eigentlich gut also ich nehme das jetzt
einfach mal als kompliment oder er hasst
mich weil ich auch spiele spieler wie
polizei ddp
kommen wir zum besten kommentar wegen
solchen kommentaren weil ich wusste dass
solche leute gerettet werden mache ich
die übrigens zensierung ich sehe sie
einfach die kanal namen
das war ironie falls du es nicht
verstanden hast schule über minecraft
würde ich den lehrer immer töten
ich möchte da ehrlich gesagt jetzt kein
bild einfügen wo ich die fehler
unterstreiche weil es einfach so
aussehen würde schon über minecraft
würde ich den lehrer immer töten
vielleicht meint er auch wenn man eine
scholle über das minecraft spiel legt
dann kommt eine windböe die einen lehrer
töten wird ich werde auf jeden fall nach
einmal ausprobieren ich werde wieder
eine tolle kaufen im supermarkt auf das
micro spiel drauflegen
vielleicht ist das dann so eine art wind
tanz und die tötet die ich habe die
lösung der hat das warten animations-
video geschrieben aber er meint die
minecraft facts folge wo ich gesagt habe
dass minecraft in schweden als schulfach
genutzt wird teilweise und da meint er
dass er in der schule in der wenn es in
der schule mannschaft geben würde würde
meine studium würde er den leser immer
töten also erfülle wenn es minecraft als
schulfach gebe in dem spiel immer den
lehrer töten
ich bin ich sollte wirklich was sollte
ich dann werden wenn ich sowas
entziffern kann hier auch wieder ein
sehr sehr schöner kommentar hashtag luca
der looser
das nennt sich lose du kleiner türken
kaminfeger user mit zwei l du [ __ ]
freunde
ich weiß echt nicht was ich zu so was
sagen sollen vor allem da kommen ja noch
was mit 26 vor allem wenn man es mal
ganz genau nimmt mit zwei euro zweimal
sind also lose und tricks verstehens
tricks okay wenn man bei google eingibt
srx also drückt dann kommt die srx serie
von cadillac
aktuell wollte ja uns darauf aufmerksam
machen freut ich habe die lösung warum
seine rechtschreibung vormarsch ist der
hat das aus dieser neuen srx reihe von
cadillac geschrieben und natürlich beim
autofahren am handy sein ist natürlich
echt nicht cool
deswegen freunde ich denke dass für die
lösung seien auch ein sehr schöner
kommentar dislike neuen daumen hoch
also es ist jedem selbst überlassen ob
er ein video jetzt positiv oder negativ
bewertet positiv wäre schon cooler
statistiken zeigen halt auch dass die
leute die solche videos positiv bewerten
geringere verdacht auf altersschwäche
und herpes haben außerdem ist der weg
zum daumen hoch geben ein wesentlich
kürzerer als der zum daumen runter geben
dh ihr müsst nicht zu viel bewegen und
bleibt dadurch ferry ich kann das video
nach einer minute nicht weiter schauen
sonst bekomme ich noch augenkrebs zu mir
leid wenn ich jetzt schon so leicht dass
man da von augenkrebs bekommt ich sehe
da ziert das unter das video geschrieben
von dem spiel was ich gestern hoch
geladen hatte also dieses komische wo
ich die ganze zeit diese komischen
farbwechsel waren dann ist das natürlich
verständlich weil ich hatte dann auch
auftrieb so musste mit wahrhaft auf
augenkrebs in das krankenhaus
eingeliefert werden
nee das war imponierend alle die jetzt
im juni wieder nicht verstanden haben
aber das war wirklich so dass es hat
mich auch selber beim zocken mega
editiert dass er die ganze zeit von blau
oder an seinen sohn grünen unserem geld
unseren ping dann wieder von vorne dann
die mucke sagt johnson
der sehr komisches spiel normalerweise
beleidige ich niemanden aber du scheiß
poser machst einfach es an dieses intro
nach und zwar dann auch noch schlecht da
du nicht tanzen kannst
jetzt mal abgesehen davon dass sich
derzeit eigentlich überhaupt kein
richtiges intro habe weil ich mein altes
irgendwie nicht mehr mark und deswegen
nicht mehr benutzen sonst auch
eigentlich keins habe außer perfekt und
commands kann ich eigentlich gar kein
intro nach machen wenn du dieses
komische in trotha mainz was sich vor
dem einen video da gemacht habe vor
diesem ein video gemacht habe
die vom einen komischen augenkrebs spiel
wurde ich so kurz bisschen so getanzt
habe am anfang oder irgendwie so habe
ich ja gemacht wenn ich tanzen nach
gemacht haben soll
dann frage ich mich wo das hingeht
derzeit hey du da ja du mal bitte auf zu
atmen weil ich atme schon das darfst du
nicht dass danach gemacht von mir weil
ich war der allererste der geatmet hat
und ich dementsprechend darf halt nicht
tanzen weil es an die schon vor mir
getanzt hat so ist das nun mal dabei
hört auf jeden fall mit der erst mal auf
zu atmen und ich weiß ich hab gesagt ich
zensiere die ganze zeit diese
kommentarschreiber aber wenn man bei
google plus sein youtube konnte mit
google+ zu verbunden hat kann man ja
einen doppelnamen nehmen die man dann
nicht über den namen findet aber den
namen muss ich euch wirklich zeigen ich
bin euch jetzt mal den typen einer das
geschrieben hat
die tiefe ich weiß nicht was heute alle
mit diesen pdp haben aber naja
ich glaub da brauche ich überhaupt
nichts mehr zusammen
kennt ihr das wenn ihr so tage gehabt
und ihr denkt euch ich bin ich habe
verpennt heute morgen es regnet raus und
ich habe die klausur vertagt die ist
dass das habe ich zwar heute nicht aber
so geht es mir grad bei den kommentaren
natürlich suche ich die selber raus aber
ich habe jetzt meinen zeitraum von einer
woche zentrale rausgesucht und ich denke
mir die ganze zeit ist kann nicht
schlimmer werden aber es wird noch
schlimmer
und zwar schaut euch das mal an
nobs learned to play to the track
zwar kann ich noch learn to play to this
truck is free to play to versus von
regus center heraus kann ich noch learn
to play to versus war ich recht
irgendwann später kann ich noch freunde
der folge kommentar spiegelt so meinen
wunsch kommentar eines wunsch users
unter einem wunsch video von mir wieder
flott warum ok dieser usernamen spitz
kopfnüsse gurke lpa grundsatz ab juli
bei uns kein dawson min kraft schreibt
er checkt er ihm einen channel
ausrufezeichen ausrufezeichen
ausrufezeichen aus und 2 hinaus und
seien auch so sehr freuen das war nicht
meine ganze name es geht tatsächlich
noch länger und zwar steht dahinter noch
abonniert mich auf diesen kommentar von
dem nutzer der nicht mal seinen eigenen
nutzernamen richtig schreiben kann ich
meinen da ist ein fehler ins da sind 241
klar dass minecraft dessen fehlern
abonniert alles mögliche falsch er kommt
einen kommentar darunter von die tribute
von panem fan akp peka peka freunde da
war ich dann echt froh über meine
zuschauer dass sie da sagen nee und dann
kommt dieser kommentar von der gewissen
person mein mann sci nat
schon nett da habe ich übrigens auch
nichts zensiert weil die ganzen namen
auch auseinander geschrieben sind also
die kann man quasi eben nicht auf
youtube finden
ich weiß echt nicht was ich dazu sagen
soll
hätte ich eigentlich ganz hinter der
kamera oder in den kommentaren drin oder
so ich glaube steigen die so sitzen ich
heute da ich nicht mehr viel zeit habe
und ich auch nicht hier mir die ganze
zeit so hast mich lesen kann
kommen wir zum abschließen konter der
sehr schön war unter einem instagram
bild von mir denn freunde
das war auf jeden fall das video für
heute ich habe mir gedacht da das
zurzeit viele leute mal machen einfach
so gegen entgegengesetzt dieser ganzen
hate werde die zurzeit auf youtube
umgeht und auf twitter hat weiß ich wo
ich mir gedacht und auch andere youtuber
das werden wir mal so ein paar böse
kommentare rausnehmen oder komische
kommentare die einfach mal vorlesung das
ganze ein bisschen auf den arm zu nehmen
wenn euch das video aber eventuell sogar
gefallen hat und eventuell sogar mehr
davon wollen wir ja so nett kommentare
oder so komische kommentaren komischen
nutzern ja immer mal wieder kommen würde
ich mich darüber freuen wenn ihr das
video positiv bewerten würde bzw
den kommentar schreiben würde tvoe sagt
ob ihr so was vielleicht auch mal haben
wollt ich hatte auf jeden fall denke ich
viel spaß nachbearbeitung weil ich mir
schon vor seiner art skript dazu
geschrieben habe wie ich das ganze
machen werde
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen und wir
sehen uns dann anders wieder detail
kommt übrigens sehr geiler prank sag ich
mal schon mal aber wir sehen uns dann
die lage